>> Dana: DEMOCRAT CIVIL WAR IN
D.C., ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
NOT HAPPY WITH HER OWN PARTY FOR
ALLOWING A COVERT ERA
EVICTION MORATORIUM TO EXPIRE.
AOC IS THREATENING TO BLOW
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL
IF OUR LEFT DEMANDS FOR
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN MORE
SPENDING AREN'T PUSHED THROUGH
CONGRESS.
THE HOUSE AND HOUSE LEADERSHIP
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE TO EXTEND THE MORATORIUM.
AND THERE WERE MANY HERE WE OF
CONSERVATIVE DEMOCRATS THAT
THREATEN TO GET ON PLANES RATHER
THAN THIS VOTE.
WE HAVE TO RELATE JUST CALL A
SPADE A SPADE.
WE CANNOT IN GOOD FAITH BLAMED
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY WHEN HOUSE
DEMOCRATS HAVE THE MAJORITY.
IF THERE IS NOT A RECONCILIATION
BILL IN THE HOUSE AND IF THE
SENATE DOES NOT PASS THE
RECONCILIATION BILL, WE WILL
UPHOLD OUR END OF THE BODY AND
NOT PASSED THE BIPARTISAN BILL
UNTIL WE GET ALL OF THIS.
>> Katie: DANA WHY IS THIS
YOUR FAVORITE STORY?
>> Dana: THE MORATORIUM IS MY
FAVORITE BUT LET ME COMMENT ON
ONE THING AND THEY WANT TO HOLD
UP THEIR END OF THE BARGAIN BUT
SHE'S PLAYING WITH A SMALLER
HAND SO THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
IS GOING TO PASS THE SENATE AND
HAS THE POTENTIAL OF GETTING
REPUBLICAN VOTES.
THE RECONCILIATION BILL HAS NO
CHANCE OF ANY REPUBLICAN VOTE.
SHE CAN TALK ABOUT THE HOUSE
MARGIN, BUT THAT DOES NOT
MATTER.
AND SHE IS MAKING THE SENATOR'S
LIFE SO MUCH BETTER AS SHE SITS
THERE AS MODERATE DEMOCRATS, I'M
TRYING TO BE PRAGMATIC AND GET
THINGS DONE.
GOOD FOR HER POLITICALLY.
IMAGINE FOR ONE MOMENT, JUST
FORGOTTEN.
EXTENDING THE EVICTION
MORATORIUM.
AND SPEAKER PELOSI PUTS OUT
SATURDAY NIGHT LAMING
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
THE ONLY REASON IT WAS EXTENDED
FOR ANOTHER MONTH OR TWO
BRETT KAVANAUGH SAID FINE, I
WILL DO WITH THIS TIME, BUT THIS
IS NOT CONSTITUTIONAL.
CONGRESS NEEDS TO DO SOMETHING.
THEN THEY SAT ON THEIR HANDS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN, DOES HE THINK
THE SENATE SHOULD EXTEND IT?
NOT ALL LANDLORDS ARE
WARREN BUFFETT.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN, BACK RENT.
BUT HERE'S THE KICKER OF ALL OF
THIS, REMEMBER WHEN STATES COULD
NOT GET UNEMPLOYMENT MONEY OUT
AND IT WAS SO FRUSTRATING?
WHY ARE WE AS THE FEDERAL
TAXPAYER OFFERING MORE AND
WILLING TO PAY ALL OF THIS IN
THE STATE CAN'T GET MONEY TO
EVERYBODY AND NOT ABLE TO PAY
ELECTRICITY BILL AND THE STRESS
THROUGH NO-FAULT OF THEIR OWN IS
HAPPENING BUT NOW THIS CASE THE
FEDERAL TAXPAYER GETS
$49.6 BILLION TO THE STATE AND
THEY CAN'T FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
THIS MONEY OUT, THEY SAT ON IT
IN NEW YORK $2.7 BILLION IN THE
DEMOCRATS TURNED AROUND AND SAID
ACTUALLY THE LANDLORDS ARE TO
BLAME.
THE LANDLORDS SHOULD APPLY FOR
THIS MONEY.
I THINK THIS IS ABSOLUTE
INCOMPETENCE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
AND ACTUALLY COME UP PEOPLE KNOW
THAT THIS MORATORIUM NEEDS TO
END BUT HEAR ME OUT ONE LESS
THING.
IF THEY PASS THE MORATORIUM FOR
ANOTHER FOUR OR FIVE MONTHS,
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
CHRISTMAS.
DO YOU THINK ANYBODY WILL WANT
EVICTION NOTICES GOING OUT AT
CHRISTMAS?
THE MORATORIUM NEVER ENDS.
THEN WHAT HAPPENS?
YES, THIS IS MY FAVORITE STORY
FOR DIFFERENT REASONS.
I DIDN'T EVEN GET ABOUT SLEEPING
ON THE SOFA OF THE CAPITAL.
>> Greg: YOU TALK ABOUT IT,
NO, YOU GO.
>> Katie: DO YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT SLEEPING ON THE STEPS OF
THE CAPITAL WHEN MILLIONS OF JOB
OPENINGS AND RESTAURANTS HAVING
HARD TIME GETTING WORKERS BACK
TO WORK AND HAVING A HARD TIME
AND THEY ACTUALLY OWED TO THE
BANK AS WELL?
>> Richard: IT IS A BALANCED
APPROACH.
AND DANA POINTED OUT $50 BILLION
OF MONEY TO SET TO DEAL WITH THE
FACT THAT BOTH THE LANDLORDS
BEHIND THE MORTGAGES AND THE
RENTER THAT CAN'T FIND JOBS OR
WORK FOR VARIOUS REASONS AND
THIS MONEY SHOULD BE USED BUT
THE CENSUS BUREAU SAYING BECAUSE
ACCORDING TO THE CENSUS BUREAU,
3.6 MILLION FOLKS WILL BE
IMPACTED WHEN THIS MORATORIUM
GOES AWAY.
SO THIS IS ABOUT GOVERNMENT
WORKING FOR THE PEOPLE.
BOTH STATE, FEDERAL AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND CORI BUSH FOR
SLEEPING ON THE STEPS OF THE
CAPITAL JUST BECAUSE WE ARE
HAVING A CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS
ISSUE.
WAIT A MINUTE, WHERE DID THE
$60 BILLION GO AND HOW DID THE
$60 BILLION GET TO THE RIGHT
PEOPLE, WHICH IS WHAT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS TRYING TO SAY?
WHERE IS THIS MONEY AND WHY
HASN'T IT GOT TO THE PEOPLE THAT
ALLOCATED IT?
CONGRESS PASSED IT AND HOW DO WE
NOT GIVE THIS TO THE RENTERS TO
BEGIN TO PAY THIS MONEY SO THEY
CAN STAY IN THEIR HOMES AND NOT
BE VICTIMS.
>> Katie: JESSE, WHY ARE THEY
NOT HAVING THIS CONVERSATION IN
JUNE WHEN IT IS CLEAR THAT IT
NEEDED TO BE PASSED IN CONGRESS?
>> Jesse: THEY WERE FOCUSED ON
JANUARY 6TH, KATIE, THAT IS WHY.
AOC NEEDS TO PAY FOR SOMEONE
ELSE'S RENT, NO, I DON'T KNOW
IT'S NOT.
HE HELPED A LOT OF AMERICAN
PEOPLE WITH WHAT, FREE MONEY,
FREE RENT FOR NEARLY A YEAR WHEN
THEY NEEDED IT.
THEY DON'T NEED IT ANYMORE AND
THEY CAN HELP THEMSELVES.
WHAT DID JOE BIDEN SAY?
THIS WAS A WORKERS JOB MARKET?
THE WORK LAST, YESTERDAY, 62
COVID DAD DEATHS, AND 102 PEOPLE
DIED IN CAR ACCIDENTS, OKAY?
SO WE HAVE TO NEUTRALIZE THE
THREAT OF COVID WITH VACCINES.
AND WE KNOW THAT AOC WANTS THIS
AND SHOW IT'S IN THE
GREEN NEW DEAL AND SHE EVEN
WROTE IT.
SHE'S ACTUALLY ON THE COMMITTEE
AND SHE DIDN'T SEE THIS COVERED.
AND SHE TRIED TO GET SUPPORT FOR
IT BUT SHE WAITED FOR THE LAST
MINUTE AND BLAME THE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE FOR IT.
AOC IS THE LEAST EFFECTIVE
MEMBER OF CONGRESS MAMA
BASICALLY.
SHE HAS NEVER WRITTEN A BILL
THAT HAS GOTTEN TO THE COMMITTEE
AND HER ENTIRE CAREER.
SHE IS NOT AN EFFECTIVE
LEGISLATURE.
SHE WOULD BE MUCH BETTER ON
CABLE NEWS.
>> Richard: YOU TALK ABOUT HER
QUITE A BIT, JESSE.
>> Jesse: ALL THE STUPID
THINGS SHE DOES.
I SAY WE TALK ABOUT PEOPLE DO
THAT IS STUPID.
SPEAK TO GREG, BROUGHT ABOUT A
MOVEMENT, THE FAR LEFT
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS THIS
MOVEMENT GOING ON FOR A LONG
TIME.
UNIVERSAL INCOME AND THE
GOVERNMENT PAYING EVERYTHING AND
THAT PRIVATE BUSINESSES GETTING
OFF OF THE HOOK.
>> Greg: THIS IS THE REASON
YOU CAN'T COMPROMISE WITH
TEMPORARY SOLUTIONS.
EVEN IF YOU GIVE A TEMPORARY
SOLUTION TO AN ELECTIVE, THEY
WILL MAKE IT PERMANENT.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING WHETHER
MAIL AND PALLETS ARE MORATORIUM,
YOU GIVE THEM -- SURE, WE WILL
GET BACK TO NORMAL.
NO, THEY WON'T COME A MORATORIUM
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
AND I HAVE TO SAY WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT HER AT ALL.
WE TALK ABOUT THE STORIES AND
ALWAYS VERY, VERY RESPECTFUL.
SHE'S INCREDIBLY TALENTED, BUT
SHE HASN'T LIVED ENOUGH TO BE
THAT ARROGANT IN HER WISDOM HERE
THAT IS AN ISSUE WITH THE
PROBLEM WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS THAT THEY
ARE HARD, LOONY LEFT ARE YOUNG
AND IGNORANT IN TERMS OF WISDOM.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW THE WORLD
WORKS.
AND THEY WILL NOT LISTEN TO ME.
I SAID THIS BEFORE, "THE FIVE"
WE RAISE THE FLAGS, CALLED OUT
THE CULTURE, THE MOB MENTALITY,
BUT WHEN WE DO IT IT DOESN'T
LAND WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
SO YOU NEED THE REMAINING,
SENSIBLE I.E. OLDER DEMOCRATS TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY, YOU KNOW,
PRETEND YOU DIDN'T HEAR FROM US.
MAKE IT YOUR IDEA AND WE WILL
SALUTE YOU.
BUT IT IS TIME FOR OLD PEOPLE
AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO TAKE